she represents California's 45th
congressional district and is a
professor at UC Irvine School of Law
Katey Porter alright so we're gonna talk
about the Amazon later it's depressing
me I'm sure it's depressing you let's
talk about the company or the forest
well that's what I want to get to I
think the company should buy the forest
I think we should buy the Amazon money
talks right well like we would do both
Greenland well if we're gonna buy
Greenland we might as well buy the
Amazon - yes Bezos has a hundred and
thirty billion Ted Turner used to do
this he is to buy giant swaths of land
cuz he said nobody else is gonna say but
I will where are all these cheap
billionaires when you need them these
environmentalists put your money where
your mouth is money's only gonna talk
yeah but there is a billionaire named
Jamie Dimon who is head of what bank JP
Morgan JPMorgan Chase okay and you sort
of became famous cuz you shamed him you
were grilling him about why in his I
think to be fair you think he shamed
himself well you helped the student who
would tell me that they were really
upset that I asked them a question to
which they didn't know the answer to
which I would be like well that that's
sort of well apparently he's never
thought about the answer because that's
what he kept saying to you you kept
saying you know someone who works at
your company in a secretarial position
only makes this much money and that's
hard to live on but you know your
company does quite well and he said see
I never thought about that but the other
day he was talking and a lot of business
leaders were about how they've changed
their tune a little bit that they say
companies should be responsible in the
way Henry Ford was you know make the
workers solvent and maybe they'll buy
your product and other products so it
looked to me like shaming works I've
said for a long time I don't think we
shame enough you shamed him don't you
think we should do that
I do think holding people
countable works and I think it works in
multiple ways I think it obviously
worked to push the Business Roundtable
toward this new definition of a
corporation but it also works in giving
the American people confidence in our
Congress so those hearings they're not
for me those hearings are for the
American people so this is not my five
minutes this is our five minutes and so
the goal would like a lot of my
colleagues don't get this and so they'll
say to me like wow Kati like you're a
freshman but you're so good at asking
questions like do you have any tips and
so it's really hard to figure out how
you say politely like well the first tip
is ask a question like an appointed one
I mean to be honest he looked like I do
not want to ever answer this lady's
questions again no like that is my
screensaver it's like the but and you
were pointing out something that came to
light again this week because that ice
raid in Mississippi last week where they
threw a lot of people out of work and
probably now out of the country they're
trying to replace those people and it
was in the paper how much the jobs are
these are horrible jobs murdering
chickens it's like $10 an hour $12 an
hour this is just what you were talking
about how do I've said this often how do
people live in this car how do you pay I
mean I've been dirt poor too but I was
single I'd have to worry about kids who
are interested in our vacuums for money
how do you pay for all the things that
you need to pay for $400 a week families
can't so what they're doing is they're
going without they're going without
prescription drugs they're going without
dental visits they're going without
savings they're going without emergency
funds and they're borrowing they're
borrowing on credit cards they're
borrowing from predatory lenders I mean
this is the reality of not earning
enough and so really what the Business
Roundtable said and what Jamie Dimon
said Jamie Dimon's quote was the
American Dream is alive but Frank and I
saw that quote and I thought well so
nice of Elizabeth Warren to give such a
great quote Jamie Dimon could have ran
Elizabeth Warren when he said the
American Dream is alive but Frank I'm so
glad because he shamed him has realized
what I was trying to tell him which is
for his own workers at his own base in
Orange County California they can't make
ends meet they can't afford an apartment
much less safe or anything and so the
Business Roundtable have said look
shareholders aren't everything
and that is the first time ever I tell
you as I've someone who graded exams in
corporate law the correct answer to any
question in corporate law until Monday
was shareholders right so khuda'
corporations through shareholders what's
the duty of a corporation shareholders
so what they said is no actually we
should worry about stakeholders which
they said means workers which means
communities which means suppliers which
means you know customers this is really
revolutionary and it's gonna make my job
questioning these witnesses so much
you mention elizabeth warren elizabeth
warren was your professor i didn't
realize that also your mentor you named
your daughter after her but you're not
endorsing her i have not endorsed anyone
yet and i have a really hard time I mean
I gotta tell you like I have a little
bit of a sob story here I have three
children I'm a single mom so while I'm
trying to get the tater tots unstuck
from the there's no juice at dinner bill
I'm sorry for you my children I have a
Booker voter he's 13 I have a comma low
voter who's 11 and I have a I'm named
for her Elizabeth Warren voter my
daughter Elizabeth and as soon as I get
the family vote consolidated and we come
up with a candidate that I'll be in the
position to do more but I really want to
help you truthfully when I tell my
constituents my vote and my choice isn't
what's at stake here what's at stake is
every single person's choice
so we can't leave anything on the table
we have to connect with from Orange
County which until very recently like
two years ago was all like I like
straight Reagan County you know still
today i represent proud to represent a
majority of Republicans right and those
are Republicans who have good sense but
all the districts didn't all didn't all
the Orange County districts go blue
correct okay so you have to be I would
guess a little more in the center to
appeal to your constituents Elizabeth
Warren I mean I love her but I hear a
lot of analysts say things like we'll
lose 40 states Elizabeth that's a 40
state loser election what do you think
about that I think that we should let
the candidates run and win and in some
cases like the last couple days running
loose right but she's running in the
primary which is not the general
election in a way you're practicing
against the team that resembles nothing
like the team you're gonna fight in the
game that counts fair point but we also
have an opportunity we also have an
opportunity to add more players to our
team to turnout younger voters to turn
out people who don't vote consistently
so our team is not a fixed thing
and by the way the game is not a fixed
thing either so when you like I say this
is someone like the thing that Bond's
the freshman class together
everybody from Abigail's fan burger to
Alyssa to Alexandria kasi or Cortez for
max Rose to Rasheeda Talib is that we
don't take corporate PAC money and we
understand that corporate abuse is
harming our capitalist economy in
Republican districts in Trump districts
in districts that have never had a
Democrat before because we understood
that what Americans want is an economy
that works for everyone and here I'm
surprised to find myself quoting Jamie
Dimon no but I shot really but Americans
don't think that the economy that works
for them is called socialism now I know
Elizabeth says she's a capitalist she I
know but that's not the way she's gonna
be painted in summer for programs let's
be honest sound pretty socialist I just
don't want another George McGovern
I was I was well you're smarter than
those kids who say it doesn't matter cuz
I wasn't alive you were in a lie for the
Civil War you know about that right yeah
okay but but I feel like things worked
out here in the Civil War than they did
for George McGovern yeah and we don't
want that and he ran against Nixon who I
think people don't realize was the tanks
were the Ted Cruz of his day and in a
product of Orange County just not a
popular guy not a likable attractive man
a sweaty loser as far as popular and and
he won 49 states I'm just saying I think
you think something like Amy Klobuchar
is actually more electable I know
Elizabeth Warren has all the you know
them and energy right now but not gonna
answer that one I'm just gonna tell you
this I think energy matters and we saw
that in 2018 yeah so we had wreck I
would not be in Congress if it were not
for Trump being terrible okay that was a
big help and my opponent making some
critical mistakes right like voting
Trump who's terrible but also because we
turn in a record turnout in 2018 so we
took our university from
2% voting to 30% voting that's how I won
I wish we knew I think the reason I kind
of react on this one is it's not so much
about Elizabeth per se it's that I have
only had every single person tell me I
couldn't win run and win as a
progressive in Orange County and here I
said I ran I won I'm working hard for
the American people in Congress I'm
asking again for their votes in 2020 and
I think that's a model that people can
look to thank you for coming by
[Applause]
you